I'm Sami zaydan you're joining us for
our special coverage of the second round
of turkia's presidential election well
this comes of course after a first round
which saw no clear winner but did see
the incumbent president emerge ahead of
his Challenger command kalashdarolu with
about five points it also saw the ruling
party Alliance dominate the
Parliamentary elections in the first
round winning a majority there well now
the big question is what will Shape Up
and emerge from the second round of
voting this is a historic Day by all
measures with the first time in this
country's history that a presidential
election has gone to a second round we
saw voters come out at 5 a.m GMT to cast
their ballots in this unprecedented vote
now looks at how things have panned out
so far in the voting
many consider this election to be turkey
as most significant in its recent
history
erdogan voted in Istanbul where he began
his political carrier
he has reshaped the nation in the last
two decades
his supporters believed he has made it
more powerful Emperor's Paris
I want erdogan to win for the sake of
stability for this country
stability and continuity have been the
message throughout erdogan's election
campaign
but after more than two decades in power
he now faces his most difficult
challenge
six opposition parties have joined
forces for this presidential runoff with
opposition leader Kamal khalestarolo
chosen as their unified candidate
he was second in the first round on May
14th
as he came to cast his word in Ankara he
was welcomed by his supporters
they are grown more confident that he
will be Turkey's next president
the whole nation wants change because
our country wants its rights Justice and
rule of law
neither president erdogan nor the
opposition leader kalistaro consecuted
enough Wars to win in the first round it
was the high votes for nationalist
parties that forced the election to the
second round
the rise of the Nationalist parties was
the main surprise of the first round
that has forced the presidential
candidates to reconsider their election
strategy to appeal to the Nationalist
Awards in the runoff
the opposition leader kalistaro has
focused his second round campaign on
anti-refugee sentiments promising to
send home millions of Syrian Afghan and
Pakistani refugees syrians will go as
one of the main slogans written on
billboards
as a result the leader of the ultra
nationalist Victory party amid USDA has
announced his support for kalistarovo
another Ultra nationalist presidential
candidate who came third in the first
round has decided to support president
erdogan in the runoff
the preliminary results will be
announced hours after Water cast their
ballots
but this election is closely washed
especially by millions of refugees
facing fear and uncertainty
Al Jazeera Ankara
all right we're covering this election
with correspondents across the country
we've got cinemasolo in Istanbul but
first let's start with rasul Sardar he's
in Ankara watching how things have been
unfolding there particularly with the
opposition and rasul are we seeing a
last-minute push we can say by the
opposition to try and make sure they get
as many of their followers out to the
polls
indeed Sami we have just seen that the
the leader of the opposition came out
Crystal has just tweeted and warned the
people to go out and to cast their
Awards because here one thing is is
clear among these two leaders uh
president erdogan and kalistaro whoever
can mobilize his supporters is going to
emerge as Victorious tonight that's why
the turnout is quite important for both
sides and here we are in a police
station that the opposition leader
calistado also was here and cast his
word here and you can see that the
process is still continuing but unlike
the previous round we are not seeing the
long queues here and of course the
representatives of the parties officials
here are telling us that that doesn't
mean that the turnout is going to be
lower however because the process is
easier there are only two names that are
competing and so that's why it's we are
witnessing a faster process here however
the concerns are are still there so
particularly for Camel Castro that is
very very important because the scenes
assuming the office in 2010 own he has
lost several elections against President
adwon but this time the hopes were quite
High because six opposition parties they
joined their forces to defeat president
erdogan despite in the first round uh
being have been the second uh in the
first round of the election still we can
see that both came out Crystal and his
supporters believe that he could emerge
as Turkey's next president so if he lose
probably that's going to cost his
political career but if he wins that's
going to be a historic moment in Turkey
because it's going to be the first one
who defeats erdogan Sami
all right thanks so much rasul Sardar
that's great stuff Let's uh continue
this now though and take it to Istanbul
where we've got Cinema and Cinema you've
been really around in the last 24 hours
you're in diabakar earlier today you
were in uskodar at a polling station now
you're in give us an idea about how
smooth the process of voting is going
we've heard some incidents of minor
incidents or limited incidents of
tension but overall how are things going
at polling stations
well Sami first of all I must say that
people still are willing to vote both
for president aardon supporters and
opposition leader candidate can I
Callister all the supporters I I must
say that they are willing to vote
because as their leaders made the call
to go to polling stations and not to
take the first rounds votes granted but
I have to admit in Istanbul and in
eastern cities like the Albuquerque that
we were yesterday there is not much of a
big excitement because apparently people
nearly accepted the result coming from
the first round both for the government
side
presidentardo on side and queman college
side but we are seeing we are on social
media and on opposition media mainly we
are seeing reports that that show some
incidents you know people some
opposition party members being attacked
by a ruling act party supporters and
some up party supporters who want to
vote openly being pushed out by the
opposition supporters of course these
are minor incidents individual incidents
we cannot generalize it for across
turkey as in Turkey the election
regulation is tough strong and the
Safety and Security of the election is a
highly decent compared to many other
countries but of course we can say that
the tension is still there Sami and
that's why we have seen erdogan and
cholesterol calling on their people to
vote and we saw a presidential
spokesperson Ibrahim calling also making
the same call for the erdogs supporters
to go to polls and cast their ballots
but of course we don't know how the
turnout is going to be but I have to say
around here in beshiktash this is one of
the major districts in Istanbul where
you have of all Transportation
universities
corporations many other things all
around here you don't see an excitement
among people and people are tired of
election Sami because within the last
two decades turkey has been through so
many elections referendums and just in
March 2024 Which is less than a year
away Turkish people are going to cast
their ballots for their mayoral
candidates and then after sometime in
four years again they will be voting for
their presidents but of course the
people say they are going to the polls
because they it's their Democratic
rights to choose their leader and they
are voting for the future of their
children so there is this conscious
there is this responsibility but not
much of a big excitement back to you
Sami
thanks so much cinnamon you're right
Cinema appetite for voting one of the
things one of the key things people will
be watching out for in this round one of
the things people will also be
extrapolating from the first round some
of the key areas and patterns of voting
as alexio Bryan explains now
Istanbul Ankara and Izmir a turkey's
biggest cities and in the election
earlier this month all the provinces
around those cities here in red voted
for the opposition candidate Kamal
Khalid that's a shift away from Richard
type erwan who took both Ankara and
Istanbul in 2018. but this year he lost
those provinces by about one or two
percentage points and there was a much
wider margin in izmia however it
traditionally votes for the opposition
erdogan didwin as expected in the
central conservative Heartland here in
yellow his party's support base but with
fewer votes compared to 2018
he also won an eight of the 11 provinces
badly affected by those earthquakes in
February and let's suggests that's
because of the governing party's promise
to rebuild the devastated cities further
south east is where most of the Kurdish
population is concentrated the main
pro-kurdish party under the green left
Banner through its support behind
kilichterolu and Kurdish voters followed
suit
then there's Western Europe where the
vast majority of the Turkish diaspora
lives and it's 3.4 million registered
voters about 55 percent of those cast
ballots in the runoff vote that's even
more than in the May 14 election when 57
of them voted for erdogan and the
candidate who finished third in the
first round senon Owen won about five
percent of votes overall he has endorsed
erwan to win
but it's unclear how Owen's supporters
will vote in the runoff and what that
will mean for these two men and their
political ambitions
all right let's talk a little bit about
what we're seeing so far from the
turnout patterns and we are delighted to
welcome back Ali tarkano from College
University great to have you back with
us again Ali so
so far so far I think tell me is it safe
to say by International standards
turnout looks as far as we can see quite
healthy at least
but in some areas maybe less than the
first round is that the indications that
we're getting we're getting information
from isolated places that contradict one
another so I'm afraid it will be
absolutely possible to to make a
generalization from this all right how's
it looking in some of the key important
areas that everybody was saying you've
got to watch these areas when it comes
to urban areas Kurdish areas yeah
nationalistic hubs these will decide the
vote can we say anything about voter
turnout there so far well whatever you
see behind us is the key Istanbul you
have more than 10 million voters here
the turnout here is it higher than
before or lower we get conflicting
information at least I do get
information from family friends
suggesting one places have one place is
down
um the other places are Southeast and
Eastern Anatolia where the Kurdish
population
is dominant
there's the turnout had been lower than
the national average in the first
election how are they doing now
and will they turn out in the last
couple of minutes we still have about 10
hours if not less so the leaders are
calling for their followers to come out
and vote I'm doing do we have any sign
that people are reacting to those last
minute calls by both sides well at least
what we hear is you know again isolated
but tension is rising in especially you
know metropolitan areas
and we have to wait and see if this
tension can be controlled and turned
into a Jubilation of The Winning Side
whoever that might be right one thing we
do know is that overseas voters their
turnout has been higher so far in this
round compared to the first one why is
it is it early to explain try and
explain that one well it's higher but
not very high it's about 55 percent uh
it's very difficult to travel to voting
polls if you live in the U.S only nine
locations had this facility people had
to travel hours to actually cast their
votes and they did it two weeks earlier
now they have to do it one more time so
most likely those who did vote in the
second round are predominantly those who
did not vote in the first round so
having the same individuals vote in both
rounds outside of turkey is actually all
right question Ali now do we have any
indication about those 8 million who
didn't vote in the first round what
they've decided to do in the second
we don't know I'm really trying here
together
we hope we we knew but that would
require a quite sophisticated research
and we didn't have time for that right
and we'll just have to wait and see the
results they will come out in two hours
all right and you'll be here with us to
try and monitor that I hope don't get
don't get blown away by the wind yeah
well yes the wind is picking up thanks
so much
well as Ali said we've got to wait and
see talking about wait and see a lot of
people waiting to see what happens on
one crucial issue that's been centered
on this election the issue of refugees
as Noel kormich reports it's a wait and
see issue on both sides of the turkey
and Syria border
syrians who have experienced the horrors
of War firsthand eagerly await news from
Turkey
many here have family members across the
border and want to know how this
election will affect them
I have many relatives living in turkey
and working to support their families
here the calls we're hearing about
deporting syrians who are living there
would have very bad consequences
especially on a humanitarian scale
safe
the display series have been supported
by humanitarian Aid coming through the
northern Turkish border
but they fear that it might disappear
for good
no matter who wins we hope that turkey's
approach will not follow the approach of
deporting syrians which will have dire
future consequences on the humanitarian
sector here as more than 1.8 million
people are already living in refugee
camps
turkey as elections could also alter the
Region's political landscape president
erdogan's government has sent troops to
Northern Syria and has been coordinating
with this year in opposition for years
and political activists believe the
policies of whoever wins
will shape the future dynamics of the
entire region
the Turkish elections have great
significance for the Syrian issue these
elections have an effect on syrians
especially in the north and on syrians
presently in Turkey a as for us as a
political body in idlib of course we
believe that these elections are decided
by the Turkish people
here as North and Syria continues to
deal with the devastating effects of its
12-year War
many here wonder what the Turkish
elections will mean for them in Syria's
bustling markets there's Assemblies of
normalcy as people go about their daily
routine when we ask people here what
they think of the Turkish elections we
were met with both optimism and concern
but for now it is unclear what the
outcome of the vote will mean for
syrians and this will rather's country
the karma
adlib Northern Syria
of course the issue of refugees just one
of many on people's minds as they head
to the ballot boxes amongst the other
issues that have been raised in this
election the question of democracy the
question or allegations of autocratic
rule with International and domestic
organizations saying the rule has been
too autocratic lately with jailings of
journalists and Civil Society or people
working in social media or posting on
social media and so on let's continue
this discussion then and bring in Cedar
demarap she's a professor of political
science at echic University in Istanbul
first of all let's take the pieces the
Democratic implications of this election
Cedar
right well the opposition suggested that
in opposition Victory would mean that
even in hybrid regimes like turkey where
the Electoral competition isn't entirely
Fair it is possible to change the
government with elections so an
opposition Victory would imply that
democratization is possible with the
right campaign right election strategies
and everything so it would have a
positive good news for
democratizing countries we should also
remember said I that on the other side
would point to the history of the jeophe
the main party and say when they were in
power they have a long history of
allegations of being very autocratic in
how they ran the country as well right
right yeah but jerhape claimed that they
came a long way and they learned from
their past mistakes and in fact if we
look at their campaign we can see a
learning curve where right I mean their
recent campaign focused on fighting
poverty needs of the average voter
instead of secularism or republican
values They promoted in the past
right a bit of a battle there going on
in terms of the populist who claims the
populist cause
well I
uh between the two right and both sides
making promises targeting people's like
daily rather short-term oriented needs
and um we see we saw erdogan doing that
Ardon was big about harnessing people's
economic needs he was big in populist
politics it's more new for the
opposition so I would say the opposition
tried to invert popular strategies of
the government the ruling party against
themselves in this election talk about
inverting did we see the candidates kind
of switch roles of it in the last 24 48
hours with one sounding more inclusive
than he has and one sounding even more
harshly nationalistic than he has
well I guess we could say that to some
extent's tone is hardening at least much
uh more than other ones ardon's recent
speech at Pecos yesterday's speech was
um it included positive inclusive
messages
um we could say arduan feeling more
confident maybe making him more
inclusive and kalistano is trying harder
to mobilize more votes which pushes them
towards a more like harsher tone and a
more negative campaign all right always
good talking thanks so much for coming
back well it's what now about 38 minutes
left for people to get out and vote and
we understand according to the high
commission High Election Commission they
hope pretty soon after the votes close
they're going to have a meeting which
they will decide whether to lift the
media ban hopefully pretty soon after
that we can get into start starting to
read those election tea leaves try and
try and get some indication of who might
be forging ahead